it was pointed out in the comments for
the last video where I defined this
insertion sort that I didn't necessarily
have to do this break the logic and this
is one of those examples that sometimes
when you just program something in the
way that it at least your brain is
thinking about it you're not you don't
always do it and maybe the most elegant
way and that commenter was right there
was actually a slightly more or actually
maybe a lot more elegant way to actually
do this insertion sort so over here if
we go into the while loop I have this
while loop happening while I is greater
than or equal to zero but then I want it
- I want to essentially - break out of
that while loop if our value of variable
if the if the variable value is not less
than list the the I fell iment in list
so one way to do this because I really
have is I'm just defining the parameters
on when to do this while loop instead of
doing this if if if the value is less
than the il iment do this and otherwise
break what I could have done and this
would have actually been a more elegant
way to do this while I is greater than
or equal to zero and and value and value
is less than list less than the ithe
element in list so now what it this is
still the same as before but now I know
that value is less than the ilm in the
list so I will execute this code over
here so I know that this is going to be
true I know that this is going to be
true and I can I can auto let me take
all of these one level back and then I
don't have to do a Nelson I don't have
to break out of the loop anymore and so
that should have simplify the program a
good bit but let's verify for ourselves
that this actually works so let me save
it and then let me run it it looks like
it's so let me define let me define a
list so let me call it I'll just call it
C is equal to 1 1 5 7 6 7 2 3 4 5th 14
and - so let's just define that and
let's try our insertion sort insertion
insertion sort on C C we get so let's
see let's print let's print C now and
there you go
it's sorted it so thank you for the
comment I think this will this does
simplify it a little bit and it shows
you don't it sometimes you always have
to question especially if you have a
while statement of you know is there a
better way instead of using the break
because that's essentially I'm putting a
condition on a reason to break out of
the while loop why don't I implicitly
just put it up here